if you can't condemn genocide I don't
care whether we're talking Jews Muslims
any group of people then you don't
deserve to be you know in a position of
power you got to get out one of the guys
who's built better things is Dave pornoy
over at bar stool Sports uh Dave I is he
a graduate of Harvard or he's from
Boston area he went to right he went to
Michigan but he is uh you know he's
largely in the Boston area now big
Sports guy he created bar duel sports
right so I'm guessing Dave porner
probably was growing up wanted to be
part of ESPN ESPN goes woke he creates
his own thing it is absolutely massive
uh and he's had it with Harvard too uh
here he is on Fox Business explaining
his hiring policies going forward you
will not hire anyone from Harvard until
the school's Deans step down I think a
lot of leaders have to do it it was
disgusting what those uh Deans and
presidents did under oath uh makes no
sense to me I don't know how if you
can't condemn genocide I don't care
whether we're talking Jews Muslims any
group of people then you know deserve to
be you know in a position of power you
got to get out what about Free Speech
does that come into this yeah listen
um is Hitler allowed to say I want to
kill the Jews I want to kill the Jews I
want to kill the Jews right up till he
kills the Jews uh I I would say no and
when you're endangering people and
causing harm I think you got to put a
stop to it it's called Common Sense
isn't it interesting again I take I like
these videos of people that have that
really never would have thought they
would be in these fights whether it is
Dana when I'm praising him or whether
it's uh poroi right now like these
people who suddenly can make more as he
just said Common Sense than than the
people who were supposed to be our
sensemakers Brock just pointed out to me
actually that bar stool Sports was part
of ESPN and ESPN got rid of it because
they were kind of to edgy they weren't
going along the woke lines that even I
didn't even realize that that proves my
point even further and now he's built
something that is growing exponentially
and ESPN is having all sorts of problems
so the point ladies and gentlemen of
Today's show if you don't back down if
you do the right thing for the right
thing sake you might actually Force
change for good how do I know it well
Liz McGill from upen has resigned yes
that's right I don't need to read the
whole thing to you but after that
absolutely horrific Congressional
hearing where she could not condemn
calling for genocide of Jews and again
as Porto points out it wouldn't matter
if you were calling for genocide of
Muslims if you're calling for genocide
of white people that would be just as
bad uh now she is gone and she did it
while smiling the entire time which was
really particularly disgusting we will
find out more about Claud and gay over
at Harvard Harvard's backing her right
now but now it's coming out that she we
covered this yesterday she plagiarized
on her dissertation and you can just
sense like that thing is just going to
keep burning over there but I said it
yesterday and I meet it again Port no
saying he's not gonna hire a Harvard
grad I'm just not hiring College grads
anymore if you do not go to college if
you have virtually no education we want
you here at the Reuben report okay if
you have no idea what you're doing if
you've never been to a school you don't
know the difference between a pencil and
a pen we want you on the team resume at
rubben report.com